[Music]
Moneyball one of my favorite books and
then turned I honestly didn't think I'd
mentioned this to you backstage I didn't
I never thought Moneyball could be made
into a good movie and then it was a
fantastic movie I just didn't think it
would translate into a movie and I
thought they didn't mean me that I I
told them they were insane when they
bought it
I really didn't I didn't see how you did
it yeah and it was lucky I think it you
know it took a lot of very talented
people just actually caring about the
message of the story and to me the
message the story wasn't about baseball
it was about it was sort of like it was
about someone figuring out that baseball
players were missed valued that you
could you could find cheap baseball
players and run a baseball team with
with chief baseball players but the
point was more that if a baseball player
like who everybody you know millions of
people watch him do what he does he's
done the same thing basically for a
hundred years
if that person can be miss valued who
can't be it's sort of like the way
markets don't value people properly and
that with the way people are
misunderstood and you wrote this you you
wrote Moneyball and of course Moneyball
focuses on Billy Beane who's using all
these complex strategies to sort of
recalibrate how baseball is played think
about it differently now you coach
yes yes I coach my job you coach your
kids Little League yes are you bringing
are you sitting there I'm just picturing
you because you immerse yourself in all
of these strategies are you they're
looking at you know and I let's say the
complex theories you're fat slow kids
who get you yeah I I find the
undervalued kid but no one else about
you know I hope you don't say that to
that my fatty is slow you're undervalued
c'mere
so so I mentioned now I live in Berkeley
and in in Berkeley the it's not a
completely that it's a it's a very sweet
and protective and liberal environment
and the kids are not encouraged to
compete so you know a strikeout as
cheered as much as a homerun nobody's
'la you're not allowed not only you're
not allowed to know the score the score
is kept only to make sure that no team
is winning more than half its games it's
it's not an environment in which the
ruthlessly competitive it's ridiculous
right so every kids you strike out in
they're handed a giant trophy is it so
so yeah yeah so but it's but it's
interesting to watch this because so
they're like the kids are like they're
like small furry animals on an island
without predators they just they have
they just have no sense of
self-preservation right I also run the
the competitive travel programs that
come out of Berkeley and well so we take
these kids and we have to train them so
they have to play against Republicans
and it's the most amazing thing to see
these kids learn that they're
Republicans who do things a different
way right and that who are about to kind
of rip their throats out kind of things
so so it's that's when the Moneyball
strategies kick in when the only time I
get any respect is when we act go out
and when people actually care about
whether they want to lose nobody the
truth is no they don't listen to me good
would be sickness with kids
you